>> DID YOU HAVE ANY SIDE EFFECTS
AFTER THE SECOND SHOT, SFLPT.
>> I DIDN'T HAVE ANY SIDE
EFFECTS AFTER THE FIRST OR
SECOND.
I WOULD HATE TO GET ONE NOW.
WE'LL SEE.
>> IS THAT HIGH ENOUGH?
>> IS YOUR WIFE GOING TO GET ONE
TODAY, MR. PRESIDENT?
>> SHE'S TEACHING TODAY BUT
SHE'S GOING TO GET ONE, TODAY.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO HEALTH
LEADERS LIKE THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION SAYING THAT
VACCINATIONS WOULD HELP IN
COUNTRIES THAT ARE NOT FULLY
VACCINATED?
>> WE'RE HEALTH AND DOING OUR
PART.
WE'RE ALSO GIVING THEM A GREAT
DEAL OF FUNDING TO KOVAKS WHICH
IS A VEHICLE THAT DOES THIS SO
WE HAVE PLENTY, PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET EVERYONE IN THE WORLD TO
PLAY THEIR PART, THE LARGE EARTH
PART IN THE WORLD TO GET
EVERYONE VACCINATED
>> WHAT IS THE PERCENTAGE OF THE
TOTAL VACCINATIONS THAT HAVE TO
BE IN PLACE BEFORE GETTING BACK
TO NORMAL?
>> WELL, I THINK, LOOK -- I
THINK WE GET THE VAST MAJORITY,
LIKE THAT'S GOING ON IN SOME OF
THESE -- SOME INDUSTRIES, 97%,
98%.
I THINK WE'RE GETTING AWFUL
CLOSE, AND -- BUT I'M NOT THE
SCIENTIST.
I THINK ONE THING FOR CERTAIN.
A QUARTER OF THE COUNTRY CAN'T
GO UNVACCINATED.
>> ANY NEWS ON THE
RECONCILIATION DEAL,
MR. PRESIDENT, HOW CLOSE DO YOU
THINK YOU ARE?
>> YOU KNOW ME.
I'M A BORN OPTIMIST AND I THINK
THESE WILL GO WELL.
PEOPLE WILL GET IT DONE AND I
HAVE MEETINGS TONIGHT, TOMORROW
AND -- AND THE NEXT LITTLE BIT.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF YOUR
AGENDA AND YOUR PRESIDENCY AND
WHAT'S AT STAKE?
>> VICTORY IS AT STAKE [
INAUDIBLE QUESTION ].
>> WELL, IT MAY NOT BE BY THE
END OF THE WEEK I.HOPE IT'S BY
THE END OF THE WEEK BUT AS LONG
AS WE'RE STILL ALIVE WE'VE GOT
THREE THINGS TO DO.
THE DEBT CEILING, CONTINUING
RESOLUTION AND THE TWO PIECES OF
LEGISLATION.
WE DO THAT, THE COUNTRY IS GOING
TO BE IN GREAT SHAPE.
>> THANK YOU.
[ INAUDIBLE QUESTION ]
>> OKAY.
THE PRESIDENT JUST GOT HIS COVID
BOOSTER SHOT, THE PFIZER
VACCINE.
LETS ME BRING IN CNN'S MEDICAL
CORRESPONDENT ELIZABETH COHEN
AND DR. RAIN, EMERGENCY MEDICAL
PROFESSOR AND ASSOCIATE DEAN OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AT BROWN
UNIVERSITY.
FIRST OF ALL, YOUR REACTION TO
THIS PRESIDENT GETTING THIS
BOOSTER SHOT ON CAMERA?
WHAT'S THE IMPACT?
>> I'M THRILLED BY THIS.
LISTEN, EVERYONE AGE 65 PLUS
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY WHO GOT
PFIZER AS THEIR PRIMARY VACCINE
SERIES SHOULD BE GOING OUT AND
GETTING A BOOSTER RIGHT NOW, AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS SHOWING UP
AND DOING IT ON CAMERA WILL
HOPEFULLY HELP ENCOURAGE FOLKS
TO DO IT THEMSELVES.
>> ELIZABETH, HIS MESSAGE GO GET
A VACCINE NOW, WHETHER IT'S A
FIRST DOSE WHICH HE WAS REALLY
EMPHASIZING OR A BOOSTER IF
YOU'RE IN THAT ELIGIBLE GROUP.
HE'S SAYING THERE'S NOTHING TO
FEAR.
HE'S PLAYING UP THE SENSE OF
URGENCY.
ARE SHOTS READILY AVAILABLE FOR
ANYONE ELIGIBLE WHO WANTS ONE?
>> THEY ARE READILY AVAILABLE.
I MEAN, THERE ARE PLENTY SITTING
ON SHELVES FOR ANYONE WHO NEEDS
ONE, WHETHER IT'S YOUR FIRST,
SECOND OR NOW YOUR THIRD SHOT.
AS DR. RAINY SAID, THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT.
AMERICANS HAVE NOT SEEN THEIR
PRESIDENT GET A COVID-19
VACCINE.
DONALD TRUMP WAS VACCINATED BUT
NOT ON CAMERA.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO BUILD
CONFIDENCE.
IN HE'S DOING, IT IT'S OBVIOUSLY
SAFE.
ONE OUT OF FOUR AMERICANS HAS
CHOSEN NOT -- ELIGIBLE
AMERICANS, I SHOULD SAY, HAS
CHOSEN NOT TO EVEN GET A FIRST
SHOT.
DOING THIS ON CAMERA, IT'S TO
HELP PEOPLE GET BOOSTERS, YES,
BUT IT'S TO REALLY ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO GET THE FIRST SHOT.
THAT'S EVEN MORE IMPORTANT.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE BOOSTERS
FOR A MINUTE AND LET'S TALK
ABOUT WHO IS ELIGIBLE.
PRESIDENT BIDEN TALKED ABOUT IT
A BIT.
IF YOU'RE MORE THAN SIX MONTH
OUT FROM YOUR SECOND PFIZER SHOT
YOU'RE ELIGIBLE IF YOU'RE 56 OR
OLDER, IF YOU'RE A FRONTLINE
WORKER, A DOCTOR, A TEACHER, A
GROCERY STORE CLERK, AN ACUT IT
LIVING IN HIGH-RISK SETTINGS
SUCH AS PRISONS OR ADULTS WITH
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS SUCH AS
OBESITY, HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE,
DIABETES.
YOU'LL NOTICE ESPECIALLY LOOKING
THAT THE LAST CATEGORY, ANA,
THAT'S A HUGE GROUP OF PEOPLE.
THAT'S AT LEAST HALF OF THE
UNITED STATES THAT IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A BOOSTER.
OBESITY ALONE IS MORE THAN 40%
OF AMERICANS, SO A LOT OF
AMERICANS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
BOOSTERS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET THEM OUT,
BUT REALLY IN MANY WAYS WHAT
TODAY IS ABOUT IS ABOUT GETTING
THOSE ONE OUT OF FOUR PEOPLE WHO
HAVEN'T EVEN GOTTEN A FIRST SHOT
TO ROLL UP THEIR SLEEVES.
ANA.
>> JUST TO PUT A BUTTON ON THE
PRESIDENT AND I WANT TO BRING IN
SEEN WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
KAITLAN COLLINS.
THIS IS A PIVOTAL TIME FOR HIM.
THE WHOLE PANDEMIC IS REALLY
THROWING HISS ADMINISTRATION NO
A BIOF A QUAGMIRE WHEN IT COMES
TO GETTING THE ECONOMY BACK ON
TRACK AND HE ENDED HERE ON HIS
AGENDA SAYING HE'S AN
OPTIMISTIC.
>> HE WAS ASKED ABOUT HOW THIS
WEEK IS GOING TO GO BECAUSE
DEMOCRATS DESCRIBED THIS AS THE
WEEK FROM HELL.
SO MUCH GOING ON AND SO MANY
DEADLINES FACING THEM AND YOU
SAW THE PRESIDENT SPEAKING
REPORTERS AS HE WAS GETTING THE
THIRD DOSE OF THE VACCINE SAYING
THERE ARE THREE THINGS THEY NEED
TO DO THIS WEEK, AND ONE IS
RAISING THE FEDERAL DEBT LIKE,
OF COURSE, THE BORROWING LIMIT
THAT THEY HAVE, THE DEBT
CONTROLLING AND HE TALKED ABOUT
FUNDING THE GOVERNMENT AND WE
KNOW THAT FUNDING IS SLATED TO
LAPSE ON MIDNIGHT THURSDAY NIGHT
AND THEY ALSO TALKED ABOUT
GETTING THESE TWO PIECES OF
LEGISLATION PASSED.
ONE IS THAT $1 TRILLION
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN
THAT PELOSI SAYS THEY WILL VOTE
ON ON THURSDAY.
THE OTHER, OF COURSE, IS THE
MUCH BIGGER PACKAGE THAT IS FAR
FROM FINISHED BUT THEY ARE
HOPING TO AT LEAST GET SOME KIND
OF AGREEMENT WHERE THEY CAN SAY,
YES, WE DO HAVE THE COMMITMENT
FROM ALL 50 DEMOCRATIC SENATORS
THAT THEY WILL VOTE FOR THIS.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT HOUSE
PROGRESSIVES WANT TO SEE AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS STARING
THEM DOWN AND.WAS SAYING THAT
HE'S GOING TO BE WORKING ON THIS
TODAY, TONIGHT AND THE REST OF
THE WEEK THOUGH IT'S NOT CLEAR
THAT THEY WILL GET ALL THAT HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED THIS WEEK.
HE SAYS HE'S OPTIMISTIC ABOUT A
TIMELINE, BUT TO BE CLEAR
THERE'S A LOT TO GET DONE
BETWEEN RIGHT NOW AND THEN.
WHAT'S FUNNY IS WATCHING HIM GET
THAT AS HE WAS GETTING HIS
CORONAVIRUS VACCINE, STILL
ANSWERING THESE QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT THIS AGENDA THIS WEEK IS
GOING TO LOOK LIKE, ANA.
>> IT'S ALL ABOUT MULTITASKING,
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE THE
PRESIDENT.
DR. RAIN RE, BACK TO THE BOOSTER
QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU GOT A MODERNA OR A
JOHNSON & JOHNSON VACCINE
INITIALLY, SHOULD ANY OF THOSE
PEOPLE BE GETTING THE PFIZER
BOOSTER LOT.
>> NO.
THEY SHOULD NOT.
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO DATA
SUPPORTING THAT MODERNA OR J&J
RECIPIENTS WOULD DO WELL OR
THERE'S SAFETY BEHIND GETTING A
PFIZER SHOT AT THIS POINT.
WE KNOW WE HAVE DATA AROUND THE
CORNER COMING ON MODERNA
BOOSTERS WHICH WILL LIKELY BE A
LOWER DOSE THAN THE ORIGINAL
MODERNA SERIES.
WE ALSO HAVE A PRESS RELEASE
ABOUT J&J BOOSTERS THAT WAS
REALLY PROMISING, BUT THE EVEN
BETTER NEWS FROM MODERNA AND J&J
RECIPIENTS THERE'S LESS EVIDENCE
THAT THOSE TWO HAVE WANED IN
EFFICACY AGAINST THE DELTA
VARIANT THAN THERE IS FROM
PFIZER AND EVEN FROM THE PFIZER
VACCINE, I WANT TO RE-EMPHASIZE
THE POINT THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
MADE WHICH IS IF YOU HAVE
RECEIVED YOUR FIRST TWO SHOTS OF
THE PFIZER VACCINE YOU ARE SO
PROTECTED.
YOU'RE NOT BACK TO WHERE WE WERE
IN 2020 EVEN IF YOU DON'T
RECEIVE A ABOVE THOR.
AGE 65-PLUS, PLEASE RUN OUT AND
GO OUT AND GET THE BOOSTER
BECAUSE WE NEED IMMUNITY FROM
YOU, BUT WE'RE IN SUCH BETTER
SPACE THAN WE WERE A YEAR AGO.
>> WHAT IF YOU'VE HAD A
BREAKTHROUGH CASE?
SHOULD YOU GET UP NOW OR SHOULD
YOU WAIT ANOTHER SIX MONTHS
POST-BREAKTHROUGH INFECTION?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND
IT'S ONE OF THOSE QUESTIONS WE
DON'T HAVE A WAY FOR.
IN MANY WAYS THAT INFECTION
LIKELY SERVED AS YOUR OWN
NATURAL BOOSTER AND WE FELL
PEOPLE NOT TO GET A SHOT WHILE
THEY ARE FEELING SICK.
IF YOU'VE MADE IT THROUGH A
BREWING, A COUPLE WEEKS OUT, NO
LONGER ON ISOLATION, SURE YOU
CAN GO GET A BOOSTER.
IS IT LIKELY TO HELP YOU?
WE DON'T KNOW.
>> OVER THE WEEKEND THERE WAS
BIG NEWS.
PFIZER COULD BE ASKING FOR
AUTHORIZATIONS FOR VACCINES FOR
5 TO 11-YEAR-OLDS IN JUST A
MATTER OF DAYS.
HOW WILL THAT HELP STEM THE
SURGE?
>> OH, THAT WILL REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
I MEAN, WHILE CHILDREN LARGELY
SPEAKING AREN'T NEARLY AS
ADEBTED BY COVID-19 AS ADULTS
ARE.
THEY CERTAINLY ARE.
WHEN MY HUSBAND WAS LITTLE WE
CALLED OUR CHILDREN OUR LITTLE
DISEASE VECTORS.
CHILDREN ARE REALLY GOOD AT
SPREADING THINGS AND IT'S
HELPFUL THIS CHILDREN COULD GET
VACCINATED BECAUSE THERE'S A
LOWER RISK THAT THEY WOULD THEN
INFECT THEIR GRANDPARENTSY SO
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
WITHIN DAYS PFIZER WILL MAKE THE
FORMAL APPLICATION.
THEY HAVE BEEN GIVING FDA DATA
ON THEIR CLINICAL TRIALS, ON
THEIR STUDIES ON CHILDREN FOR
SOME TIME NOW BUT THE FORMAL
APPLICATION COULD COME IN A FEW
DAYS.
IT'S ANYTHING WHAT IS ON IT, IT
WILL TAKE A COUPLE OF WEEKS AND
IT GIV